attention attention vous nous écoutez
deux par deux couples magnifique unis
par l'amour
réunis par le mariage et nous vous
disons bravo bravo mais attention si
l'un des deux de tout à coup se séparer
de l'eau faire commander sa petite
valise
il doit au moins sacrifier la politesse
du coeur par exemple on ne doit pas
annoncer la chose comme c'est si une
petite devinette pièce il ya deux genres
année cinq enfants qui va se retrouver
sur le carreau si les toits ça ça n'est
pas bien il faut prendre des formes
c'est la moindre des choses nous
déconseillons franchement les raccourcis
du genre mini série si c'est pas de ma
vie dit ne pas être lue par un pass non
non ça n'est pas d'hypocrisie non plus
pas de numéro dans ce style tu sais la
grande asperge la cie la blonde bulgare
sélectionné énorme
ouais la grande idiote et ben je pars
avec elle mais je peux te dire que ça
m'amuse pas un fou dit les choses avec
simplicité n'attendez pas de saisir la
balle au bond si votre mari vous dis
qu'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui simone
ne vous jetez pas sur l'occasion pour
répondre c'est pas s'ils ont divorcé
rappelons nous par ailleurs que l'amour
n'est pas un jeu de hasard
il est mal élevé de faire ceci attention
les yeux puis le jeu reste fesses je
m'en vais oui on recommence up pas ce
manque de bol c'est lui ginette et sans
rancune
non ça n'est pas bien de même si vous
partez très bien parti mais en douceur
sans commentaire c'est vrai abstenez
vous des critiques en plus ne dit pas
quoi tu es la vie devant toi t'as 56
sentais pas marrante mais t'es gentil
sts dans les 400 francs par mois et tu
pleures niche
elle manque d'humour et
sachez dire les choses comme elles sont
avec coeur avec générosité dit si ça ne
va pas le sien parlons réfléchissons
ouvrons-nous lucien mais ne dit pas mal
honnêtement écoute ses parents nous une
vingtaine d'années à présent on y verra
plus clair d'accord 1 il n'est pas sage
fait défaut simple ils vont pourtant
mieux dire ce que l'on a dit plutôt que
de le chanter par exemple pour faire
comprendre la situation à l'autre avec
un mauvais goût dans le genre non cette
odieuse à cet odieux c'est un fait
mieux vous dire carrément c'est la fin
mood cdu c'est dur mais c'est moins dur
que d'entendre dans le genre sado
masochistes ce qui me plaît tout c'est
que même sa taille sa grosse bouche avec
ses grosses mains des salvages steam tu
un fout l'camp fous l'camp cité dans la
peau les divines toi et quand enfin le
grand jour sera d'arriver le grand jour
du départ soit iemu soyez inoubliable
partait avec élégant lit par exemple au
revoir et peut-être demain
marie madeleine
mais il ya penalty de bouma grande que
aider à porter mes valises jusqu'au taxi
en vain le temps se chargera peut-être
de remplacer l'amour par la différence
alors ne bousculez pas la chose ne dit
pas en partant aller voir chez madame et
merci pour tous la cuisine la couture
les enfants s'étaient tues de tonnerre
au revoir